hey 42 here the world is a dangerous
place but depending on where you're from
the dangers you face can be very
different obviously a kid from war-torn
Iraq is going to be wary of completely
different things to a child from the
wilds of Canada bombs verse bears
glowing Sun versus metres of snow so
please fasten your seat belts put on
your hard hat sit down and take your
tablets and let's look at a few of the
ways that the world is trying to kill
you with all the talk of driverless cars
and uber as well as ingenious safety
systems like automatic braking it's easy
to forget that driving can actually be a
pretty dangerous activity so what is the
worst place to hop behind the wheel
right now it's a run with a rate of
about 44 per 100,000 people dying each
year on the roads
that's almost 15 times the rate in the
UK which is a third safest place to
drive in the world only beaten by Sweden
and Micronesia
however countries like Libya and Iraq
are also high on the list of the most
dangerous places to drive which is
understandable since the instability in
those regions means there is no real
policing on the roads also the condition
of the tarmac is pretty awful war has an
annoying tendency to make a big mess of
everything but there is no war in Iran
so what is the reason behind their
dangerous driving
well one main factor is actually the
country's most popular car the kia pride
made by cyber it accounts for 40% of the
cars on the road in a rap and is
described by police as a death coach and
they've even asked for its production to
be halted the government has also waded
in and one official Mohammad Reza
Manvi described it as being detrimental
to the mental health of those who are
easily agitated our slogans go I've
heard better BMW the ultimate driving
machine
Jaguar boy
one to perform the Kia pride putting the
mental in detrimental tibi fair it's not
quite as bad as the old Volkswagen
advert relieves gas pain even Iran's
neighbors are scared of the pride photos
of a few dozen new models lined up at
the border prompted one Iraqi journalist
to joke that the question for Iraqis was
quoting quote whether the pride is more
dangerous than - you might be thinking
if it's so awful why does everyone drive
it well that's largely down to the
international sanctions that have been
put on a run over its nuclear weapons
program they don't get a lot of foreign
imports so the new nuclear treaty that's
has been signed recently will hopefully
open up the trade of vehicles much to
the relief of the locals I'm pretty sure
some of them would rather brave nuclear
winter then get in the ironically named
pride once again for those people trying
to go on a trip without a car there is
always the chemical option the world
takes a lot of drugs to give you some
idea so far this year the world has
spent 120 billion dollars on illegal
substances and it's only April what's
more that doesn't include the oven
billions from prescription drugs which
are abused constantly the most
drug-related deaths per capita are found
in Iceland which may surprise you at a
rate of about 21 people per 100,000 a
lot of the other northern European
countries are high on the list as well
Finland and Estonia for example we
suspect those long winters with month
after month of Darkness can really take
a toll on your mood so it makes sense
that you might want a bit of escapism
Iceland also has the highest percentage
of marijuana users with almost 20% of
the population estimated to take it
regularly Scotland leads the world for
cocaine usage at 2.5% of the population
which is maybe why tourists have such a
hard time understanding what they're
saying and surprisingly Australia is the
world
leading user of ecstasy with about 3% of
the country taking it you would have
fought permanent sunshine and beaches
would be enough but apparently not in
the US which is very high on the list of
drug-related Deaf Nations the notorious
war on drugs is generally believed to
have failed John Ehrlichman one of
Richard Nixon's lead advisors has
admitted that the comprehensive drug
abuse prevention and Control Act of 1971
that was the real start of the war on
drugs was really a policy tool to go
after anti-war protesters and black
communities since they were the biggest
political threat to Nixon at the time
drug legalization is beginning to appear
around the world now that governments
can look at the data provided by
pioneering programs in countries such as
the Netherlands Portugal and Mexico
cannabis legalization in the state seems
to be going smoothly and cannabis legal
states have massive revenues of 5.4
billion dollars in 2015 and therefore to
rise again to 6.7 billion this year
Colorado alone generates over 10 million
dollars in tax a month for its state
government that's the power of going
green
but overdose is not the only way that
drugs can damage a country if you want
to see some of its secondary effects
then we need to look at a different
death rate the Central American country
El Salvador is the murder capital of the
world having overtaken Honduras in 2015
almost 1 in every 1,000 people are
killed every year in El Salvador 2015
was such a bad year that it's believed
one person was killed per hour
that makes El Salvador 20 times deadlier
than the US and 90 times deadlier than
the UK drugs play a big role since this
is what provides an income for the
vicious gangs that terrorized the
country some drugs mainly cocaine pass
through from South America on their way
up to Mexico under the US the jokes that
are sold in our salvador are the cheaper
form crack cocaine it also has the
world's highest unfettered
usage per capita el salvador had a
brutal 12-year civil war from 1980 to
1992 and it left the country in tatters
since that time two main gangs began to
establish themselves Mara Salvatrucha of
wise known as ms-13 and barrio 80 both
gangs actually started out in Los
Angeles ms-13 in the 80s and barrio 18
as early as the 60s but they both spread
down into Central America and are now
the two most powerful groups in El
Salvador
they are both highly organized and have
very strict codes of conduct for their
members they often have full body and
face tattoos with the numbers 13 and 18
featuring heavily depending on which
side they're on
and like the Hazzard sign on a bottle of
poison those markings are a very real
warning they are brutal in August of
2015 the government tried to enforce yet
another crack down on the gangs and they
responded by executing a dozen bus
drivers just to turn the city into chaos
the whole month was a bloodbath with
over 900 murders 52 on just one day
surprisingly the country still gets
almost 1.5 million tourists a year a
good deal is a good deal I guess just
remember to learn your gang greetings
you never know when they might come in
handy no pun intended
okay now if we forget about human
killers for a moment where do you think
you are most likely to be slain by one
of our animal kin let me try and read
your mind I bet most of you are thinking
Australia right well I see why you would
think that it seems like everything is
out to get you
spiders in your shoes snakes in your car
sharks under your surfboard crocodiles
in your pool ostriches and kangaroos
just generally hanging about looking
menacing books although these dangers
are real the actual death rate is
surprisingly low this is probably due to
good access to medical care and general
awareness of how to deal with these
creatures
finding the deadliest animal
is actually pretty tricky but it looks
like it could be nigeria i better point
out that we have discounted mosquitoes
and tetsu flies as killers here since
although they do threat a huge amount of
deadly disease they themselves are not
the actual killers so that leaves us
with our next most lethal group of
animal snakes part of the problem is
that in many countries people don't head
to hospital after being bitten choosing
local healers instead so no data is
collected in nigeria under 10 percent of
biteys i'm not sure that's actually a
word go to hospital possibly accounting
for it's very high death rate from snake
bites of 14 people per 100,000 to make
matters worse nigeria has a shortage of
anti-venom thanks to distribution issues
costs and the lack of good education in
rural areas the antivenoms are pretty
effective reducing the mortality rate by
70 to 90 percent so the government are
working on improving access across the
country if you escape the snake there's
a long line of other creatures waiting
to step off and the largest is the water
horse or hippopotamus hippos take out
almost three thousand people a year
globally being very aggressive in highly
territorial at least in africa people
are aware of the dangers but they are
part of a very peculiar story in south
america
the notorious colombian drug dealer
pablo escobar imported a wide range of
animals for his zoo including hippos
which he made free to the public
but when his empire crumbled the animals
were turned loose and hippos have
thrived in their new environment
maturing much earlier Don their African
counterparts the locals still see them
as cute and friendly but it's all fun
and games until one of them bites your
face off a final word on fighting for
any of you worried about a shark attack
he is a reassuring force you're
statistically more likely to get bitten
by Luis Suarez than a shark now we turn
to matters of the heart but put down the
flowers and definitely throw away those
fatty
chocolates because we're talking about
cardiovascular disease this is by far
the world's biggest killer with over 1
in 10 deaths being down to a bad ticker
and who leads the world as the land of
the brokenhearted well it's the
ex-soviet nation of thoth Minister the
country sits on top of a run like a cat
wrapped around its shoulders but where
we're on has a reasonable health care
system Turkmenistan is down in the
bottom 20% of the world according to a
World Health Organization report from
2000 so it's more of a Garfield's than a
Puss in Boots poor diet is another
contributing factor the Turkmen diet
consists of dishes such as plov a dish
made from rice and often very fatty
mutton then there are skewers of meats
like mutton and pork called shashlik as
well as dumplings called Monte and to
quench their first well then you want to
grab a delicious glass of Chelle a sour
white sparkling beverage made from
fermented camel's milk um I think I'd
rather have a heart attack so do what
you're told and eat up all your
vegetables or you'll get sent to your
room which isn't exactly the worst
punishment in the world but one
punishment that is thankfully
disappearing although rather slowly is
the death penalty right now 94 countries
have a legal death penalty but only 37
actively execute people of these 37 -
are in the Americas 11 in Africa 23 in
Asia and only Belarus in Europe in most
cases the punishment is reserved for
violent crimes terrorism and drug
trafficking but in a few select
countries the penalty also subtly
applies for adultery apostasy meaning to
abandon your religion and homosexuality
it's not common but there have been
executions for all of these within the
last five years come on world we're
better than that aren't we
Equatorial Guinea is currently the world
leader per capita
with eleven point five six people
executed per million beating the three
point seven per million in a round in
second place but it is definitely China
who has the itch iasts trigger-finger
since their total each year easily
matches that of the rest of the world
combined in the early 2000 the number
was in the region of 12,000 people a
year but it has now come down to around
2000 the difference in attitude to
capital punishment is not a new thing
the first country to remove it from
their law was Venezuela
all the way back in 1863 since 1989 at
least one country per year has moved to
abolish it with Fiji and Suriname being
the last - in 2015 when it comes to lust
meals a study in the u.s. showed that
fried chicken was probably the most
common request one month Phillip workman
asked that's his last meal be a
vegetarian pizza but rather than giving
it to him that they should give it to a
homeless person the prison declined his
request but across Tennessee thousands
of dollars of Pizza were donated to
shelters on his behalf by good-willed
individuals next up well more down
actually is falling it may be surprising
to hear that falling is the second most
lethal accident after vehicle collisions
and one study has claimed that it
accounts for a whopping thirty five
percent of all accidents and emergency
visits they're for your average
emergency doctor's day is probably a
couple of heart attacks a stroke a kid
who swallowed a pen lid and then someone
who fell off a roof a horse a ladder a
climbing frame or a farm trip if it's
the last one then it's probably Keith
Richards you don't need to treat him
he's clearly invincible so who leads the
way well in the red corner soon to be
the black and blue corner we have the
Titan of tumbles the prince of
plummeting its Zambia it's very
difficult to get exact data on this but
it seems like the southern African
nation is the falling cap
all of the world with a death rate of 46
people per 100,000 there's a combination
of factors here that could be the reason
behind this obviously a lack of great
medical facilities will always increase
the mortality rate as we've seen with
many of the other examples today but
maybe there is something about the
geography of Zambia that adds to it the
country is mostly a high plateau and
there are a series of hills such as the
manga hills that are difficult to cross
by car so you'll get a lot of people
climbing on foot through difficult
terrain it's also home to one of the
seven natural wonders of the world
Victoria Falls and fall you probably
will if you are one of the few brave
tourists to take a dip in the world's
most dangerous pool
Devil's pool is a natural Dell in the
rocks that occurs right on the very lip
of the tumbling water around August to
January the flow of the river is quiet
enough so that the natural rock edge of
the pool will keep you from being hurled
over the waterfall but accidents have
been known to happen so obey the rules
of the pool that's no bumming no running
and no heavy petting strangely as
dangerous as it looks you're more likely
to be one of the many people who die
each year falling out of bed around 500
annually in the US alone turns out that
falling dream is pretty lethal we turn
now to a very small country in the
Himalayan mountains with a population of
just over 700,000 it is the beautiful
kingdom of Utah it's not easy to visit
they strictly control tourists numbers
and there is a daily fee of 250 dollars
that you have to pay although it include
your trips and hotel so what is the
killer here exhaustion from all the
climbing some kind of goat attack well
the answer is actually poisoning a36 per
100,000 people it is some way ahead of
the rest of the world since everyone
else except New Guinea is under 10 per
one
thousand due to a lack of regulation
Bhutan has allowed a high quantity of
heavy metals such as chromium and
manganese to simply be forced into the
local water supply
after experiments and so on this is
especially odd since the country is
famous for being one of the world's
leading environmentally focused places I
guess they never thought of it as a
problem whereas in many industrial
nations there is a long history of
poisoning to look back at the chromium
for example was famously what
contaminated the town of Hinkley
California uncaused noticeably higher
rate of cancer covered in the Julia
Roberts film Erin Brokovich more
recently the lead poisonings in Flint
Michigan showed that we never quite know
when the water might go back it was
actually lead poisoning that poor Bhutan
in the news a few years back a man in
Switzerland was diagnosed with
heavy-metal poisoning and they found
that on his frequent trips to Putin he
had been taking an alternative medicine
and the pills were covered in red paint
high in led the man was hoping to cure
his condition of belt palsy a type of
face paralysis he was told the pills
contain the hair of a dead Bhutanese
priest but when they were analyzed no
trace was found I personally prefer my
medicine without a dead man's fringe in
him but each to their own I guess and
finally one of the most first world
problems I've ever come across the USA
leads to planet for a truly heroic way
to go averaging two embarrassing
funerals per year it's the country where
you are most likely to be crushed to
death by a vending machine at least
there'll be plenty of snacks at the wake
so the world might be a dangerous place
sometimes but let's not all get too
paranoid life expectancy keeps on
creeping up and you'll probably end up
living far longer than you wanted to it
you might still be around for series 49
of Game of Thrones for those of you that
have managed to stay alive all the way
through this video well done
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you